そう言ったら僕はものすごい喜ぶんで
やっぱこの連中はもう自分の手で自分の国をね
もう取り戻してるんだと
すごい矛盾なんですね
で イランもアッラーフ・アックバルと言って隣の国を侵略する
その隣の国アッラーフ・アックバルでこっちで
お互いに殺し合いはもうやめないんですね
それが信仰が問題なんですね
宗教は別に自由に勉強するものやと
それと政治とは関係ないんだと
というふうに それは自由にしておかないと
人間に考えるために だからスフィ
スフィという宗派があります
彼らは瞑想したり いろんなことをしたり
まあ立派に頑張ってますよ
同じイスラム教の中でも
もう別に誰とも戦うことも何ともなく
もうまあ一つのまあ神秘主義みたいな状態
ですから まあそれはそれで
うーん 仏教ではですから
物事を疑ってチャレンジしていくのはありがたいことであって
でも不善心所の一つはまた疑なんですね
これどう解釈しようかというと
このアディモッカでわかるはずなんです
この疑の心にアディモッカがないんだと
アディモッカって興味だと思うならば
何にも興味が生まれない心ってのはものすごい暗いでしょうに
聞こう見ようとか 何か考えようとか
何か知ろうとか 何にも興味が生まれてこない心
引っかからない 何にも
だから無知ですね はっきりというと
暗いでしょ そういうまあどうにもならない
聞こうともしない 理解しようともしない
だからってわかってるわけでもない
そのどうにもならない心なんですね
仏教で言ってるこの疑の心っていうのは
そういう人々もよく喋るんですよ
それでも でも疑は見えるんです
根っこから暗くて よく仏教の話にも
もうあんたこうではないか
輪廻はああだこうだとかね
もう相手にもしたくないんですよ
気持ち悪くなる 相手の波動をこちらまで受けるんだから
それでもう何も知らないくせに
もう仏教に文句言って
輪廻なんかはなんだあれはというてこと
こちらすごい元気になっちゃうんです
だって答えたくなっちゃうんです
なぜならば 知らないんだから知らないだけであって
もう戦ってくるんですよ
ということは この暗闇がない
あ この人にはもう暗闇がないんだと
もし事実知ったならば
もうそれは理解するんだと
ですから もうその辺で教えてあげて
それを教えてると まあそうかそうかとかね
まあそう言ったって もう私はね
あまりわかりません だからそんな状態だったら
もうそれは疑なんですね
それは科学的な疑いじゃないんです
ですから この不善 あの
痴根心の疑っていうのはそういう疑で
すごく暗くて もう気持ち悪いほど暗い心
次の痴根心は このウッダッチアですね
いわゆるもう元気がなく
まあ混乱の状態でもうイライラ状態で落ち着きがない心
それはこっちでは関係ない
イライラな心にでもやっぱりアディモッカがあるんです
その えーなんで そうすると十一
十一種類の心にアディモッカ
興味という心所が生まれません
ということは七十八の心に生まれるということ
その場合は線条は関係ないんだから
心 心が八十九で取るんです
線条に分ける場合はいつでも百二十一で取るんです
線条をまとめられる場合は八十九で取るんです
心は八十九で取って それから十一引いて七十八にアディモッカがないんだと
それからヴィリヤン ヴィリヤンっていうのは精進
この ヴィリヤンというものはやっぱりものすごい基本的な働きで
それなければ何も行動できないんですね
見るものにはヴィリヤなくても精進なくても見られる
精進なくても聞かれる
味わえる でも 見たものについて考えるためには
精進しなくてもついて考えなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 何をする時でも精進は必要なんです
それで仏教で精進なんかはまた違う話ですけど
でも精進は同じなんですね
わずかに自分で行動しなくちゃいけない
例えば寝ていて目が覚めるでしょ
で 起きなくちゃいけないという何か努力しなくちゃ起きられませんでしょうね
手を上げることにも下げることにも
足を出して歩く時でも一つ一つ精進があるんです
自動的にいかない 何一つも
全く自動的に起こるのは眼耳鼻舌身の認識だけ
それは自動的 努力しなくても生まれる
他の認識は全部努力しなくちゃいけない
そこでヴィリヤなんですけど
ヴィリヤがなくても ヴィリヤがいらない心は
この十種類の眼耳鼻舌身の十種類の心とサンパティッチェのサンティーラナという二つの心
サンパティッチェのサンティーラナ
えーと 領受心と スイ？スイド？受動心
ということで そこで全部
えーと あのリスト見れば全部簡単に見えます
わかりますからね えっと
十三が入るはずなんですけど
あ パンチャドゥーアラジャナ忘れちゃった
あのパンチャドゥーアラジャナ
五門陰転という心 それ一つと
それからあの眼耳鼻舌身の十と
十一ですね それサンパティッチェ
サンティーラナ入っちゃうと四つ
三つですね この六十八ページの六十九ページの六十八ページのリストを見ると
精進はあの不善意熟心の方を見てください
そちらには入ってないっていうことなんです
善意熟心にも入ってない
そこら辺だけ入ってない
[紙の音]そういう風に言った方が早いんですけど
十五ですからね またもう一つ十六になりますね
無因 唯識の一番目っていうのはパンチャドゥアラワ陳ですね
パンチャドゥア 十九 十九に生まれます
あの五門陰転を説明すればわかりやすい
五門陰転というのはこの
五門陰転というのはこの眼耳鼻舌身から
この に 何か触れたら実を聞こうという風な
この あの 状態なんです
いわゆるこの で 実を聞こうという何の状態
あのセンシティビティみたいな敏感というかね
で 体は別に何も認識してませんだけど
何か触れた瞬間にすぐそこに心が生まれる
その状態に五門陰転というんです
という心だというんです
耳は別に何もしてないんだけど
音が触れたらもう知る
聞く 知ってる ですから
その我々の五根が 五根にすぐ生まれる心があるんです
五門陰転という この心が生まれたら聞いたり見たりする
一応対象にいつでも敏感にいるというアンテナみたいなものなんです
まあすぐ受けると まあマイクロフォンにスイッチ入れておけば
なんか五門陰転状態みたいで
音が入ったらもう受け取ると
そうでないと別に何のこともないと
で 体にもそんなような状態で
マイクロフォンがオンにした状態のようなものだと
それで精進は要りませんということ
で 眼耳鼻舌身色にも要りませんし
で それからサンパティッチェナっていうのは
その受けた対象を受けると
それから すぐ分ける 瞬時に
それぐらいの細かい働き
この なんですけど ものすごい瞬間の働きで
それぐらいにはもう精進は要りません
すぐ生まれるんだと マノドゥアラワ陳と
心にはもう必要なんです
心もいつでも敏感性はあるんだけど
やっぱりそこにはもう必要です
次の心なんです たくさんディモック
ヴィリーヤ ピーティ 喜ですね
喜はまあ 喜ある心に全部生まれますからね
たくさんありますからね
あの えーと あの不善心処
不善心の場合は この怒りの瞋恨心二つあります
それはもう怒りだから喜は生まれません
憂いですからね あるのは
その二つは抜くと それからこの捨がある心は全部抜いちゃうと
ソーモナッサ・ウペッカー・サハガタ・カーヤヴィンヤーナ・チャトゥッタジャナーナ・ヴァッジタ・チッテース
難しいんだ これは 日本語で言うのは
で あのパーリ語だけ使うんだったらそんなに難しくないし
もう一応説明したものだからね
もうすぐ説明できますけど
パーリ語だったらソーモナッサ・サハガタ・心はどれぐらいありますかと
もう経験則 それだけ ウペッカー・サハガタはどれぐらいありますかと
禅定の世界では第四禅定には喜はない
第四と五ですね で 上心と言うんですか
あの 大 マハー 相応部なチッタ
相応部のチッタっていうのは二十四ありますが
そこには十二はウペッカー・サハガタですね
善心の場合は で 十二つ抜ける
で 不善心の場合は欲 貪瞋心には八あります
それで四つはウペッカーサハレテ
で 怒りの心二つも ウペ
怒りだから捨てる  痴根心もウペッカーだからそれも除くと
で それからこの十八の無因心があります
そこでソーマナ・サハーガ・サンティラーナというふうにありますし
正気心があります その二つを取る
それはソーマナ・サハーガ
そこには気が生まれる
ですから欲界心では えっと
十二プラス四 二十八と
また二つ で そこはまあ
だからチャート書くのは簡単なんですけど
セット覚えちゃえば で
それに気が生まれる それから禅定の世界に入っちゃったら
第一 二 三に生まれる 第一
二 三は十一 十一 十一ですから
それ三十三と それで全部心が数えてみてれば
まあ七十種類の心が除くんです
除く心というのは 第四禅定十一でしょうに
第五禅定十一でしょうに
それから無色界の十二ありますから
そこで二十二プラス十二でしょう
そういうふうに七十種類の心がもう除いて
十五一種類の心に気が生まれる
それからドーナツで もう一つで終わりましょう
チャンダ チャンダは欲という言葉ですから
その欲っていうのはあまり悪い意味ではないんです
まあ欲は日本語であまり悪い意味はしませんだからね
やる気みたいなもんですからね
で それはこの無因心十八に生まれません
それから二つのモームーハ・ワージタ・チッテーサ
それから痴根心二つにも生まれません
それで二十だけなんですね
他の六十九に生まれると
で まあそこまで難しいんだけど
これからは難しくないんです
このどんな心に生まれるんだから
善心にも不善心にも この六種類の
このたった六なんですよ
ですから それは別にたった六だから
勉強するのはまだそんなに大したことじゃないんです
ヴィターッカ・ヴィチャーラ・アディモッカ・ビリーティ・ピーティ・チャンダ
その六つはどんな心に生まれるかと
他の心所はもう決まってるんです
不善心所は不善心に 善心所は善心にって
もう決まってるんです
その六つだけ決まってない
どちらでも生まれる 基本的な働きですからね
欲はね まあ悪い心にも生まれる
悪いことしたいという欲が生まれるし
いい心にも生まれる いいことをしたいということだから
でも  痴根心には生まれません
欲もない もう極力暗いというか
その暗いっていうのは
この怒りの暗闇とはまた違うんですね
怒りのある人はもう暗闇で燃えてるんですね
怒りだから ポジティブなエネルギーなんですね
それポジティブじゃなくて行動的なエネルギーなんですね
この  鬱みたいに  どに暗さなんですね
この痴根心というのは
そこには欲もない 喜もない
それアディモッカもない
興味みたいなもの  時間随分飛びましたけど
じゃあ まだ難しいなったところでアビダンマの講習をやめましょう
これ以上は難しいので